Giselle is back for an enchanted sequel
that's overflowing with deep cut Disney
Easter eggs magical references and in
jokes yippee Kai movie lovers I'm Jan
and I've been re-watching and pausing
disenchanted to uncover all the
incredible little details you might have
missed disenchanted begins with a
soaring view through animated andalasia
where we get a nod to Sleeping Beauty's
royalty and we get the first of many
Beauty and the Beast references with a
girl reading a book by a fountain
surrounded by a flock of sheep meanwhile
the Firefly that lights up Pip's home is
a nod to Firefly Rey who sang My Bell
Evangeline in The Princess and the Frog
as soon as Giselle casts the spell that
turns Monroeville into the fairy tale
land of Monroe Asia the Disney Easter
eggs flow thick and fast so when
giselle's kitchen cutlery utensils and
appliances come to life and begin to
sing it's a homage to the iconic Be Our
Guest the broom that comes to life with
yellow bristle legs is a tribute to the
magical broom Mickey brought to life in
Fantasia and I love the funny little
detail of how the broom is simply
sweeping dust under the rug rather than
cleaning it away a metaphor perhaps for
how Giselle is trying to sweep away her
own problems with her magic wishing wand
rather than dealing with them when Pip
discovers he can talk in the live action
World wait how am I talking it's a
little joke about the original Enchanted
where he could only squeak in New York
and had to act out what he wanted to say
and when he exclaims Jumping Jelly
sticks we got magic that's a reference
to Sebastian's surprised remark in The
Little Mermaid when Ariel comes across a
ship
Gisele three gardeners are transformed
into a trio of fairies as a hat tip to
Aurora's three fairy godmothers and when
wicked stepmother Gisele orders them to
look after her baby Sophia you three you
look like you're good with children my
precious darling needs tending too it's
a spin on Sleeping Beauty where the
three fairies raised baby Aurora as they
tried to protect if from Maleficent's
curse and Malvina Monroe's fairy tale
villain has strong Vibes of the evil
queen from Snow White from her black
costume to her spiky crown and of course
she even has her own magic mirror which
is almost a replica of the original from
1937. Morgan's fairy tale bedroom is
located in the tower and has boarded up
Windows which is a reference to the
prison-like tower where Mother Gothel
kept Rapunzel hidden away it also has an
extra staircase similar to one at
Rapunzel's and there's a spinning wheel
with a spindle like the one that cursed
Aurora in Sleeping Beauty and which
Rapunzel also had Morgan later escapes
from the tower using bed sheets in a
riff on how Rapunzel leaves hair Tower
the painted walls of Morgan's original
room are also nod to how Rapunzel
painted hair walls and when Giselle
locks Morgan inside her room it's a nod
to how Lady Tremaine locks Cinderella
away in the attic and when Giselle
forbids Morgan from going to the
Festival because she has too many chores
what about the carpets in the hall and
the windows I can't see a thing there's
the gardening and The Sewing and The
Mending and don't forget about the
chimney's filthy business the list of
things she gives her to do is almost
identical to the one lady Tremaine gives
to Cinderella there's the large carpet
and the windows and don't forget the
garden clean the chimneys and of course
there's The Mending and The Sewing and
the laundry there's another tribute to
Cinderella when giselle's wish
transforms pip into a cat the
stepmothers don't have cute Chipmunks as
friends they have cats wow and evil ones
this is a send-up of Disney's Wicked
feline Trope and specifically Lucifer
lady tremaine's malevolent pussycat by
the way I think the animators got Pips
cat mannerisms down perfectly from his
fascination with the magic Scrolls
tassels to how he hilariously tries to
squeeze into an impossibly small box you
know that's not a litter box that's
where I live when scroll reveals it at
midnight shizelle's spell will become
permanent it's a Twist on the plot of
Cinderella were instead the fairy
Godmother's magic disappears on the
stroke of midnight it's pretty on the
nose but it's a classic the three mean
girls who make fun of Morgan in
monrolesia are a riff on the three girls
who disliked Belle in both the animated
and live-action Beauty and the Beast
movies later on they also fawn over
Tyler similar to how the trio were
obsessed with Gaston and as Morgan
begins her song Perfect The Melody has a
real ring to it of Belle the opening
song from Beauty and the Beast and like
Bell this is also Morgan's big I want
song and the splash of water behind
Morgan as she perches on the boxes of
fruit is a nod to the wave crashing on
the Rocks behind Ariel at the end of her
I want song Part of Your World during
the villain song bada we get a peek
inside malvina's cabinet of evil objects
that she plans to use against Giselle
among the villainous paraphernalia is
Maleficent's cursed Spinning Wheel the
enchantress's enchanted Rose the wicked
Queen's poisoned Apple a drink me potion
bottle like the one that shrunk Alice in
Wonderland and this hourglass might be a
reference to the one in which Jafar
trapped Jasmine unlike Giselle or
Malvina you don't need a magic wand or
fairy tale fight to get yourself a fancy
title as thanks to the sponsor of this
video established titles you can become
your very own Lord or lady established
titles is based on a historic Scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as Lords so you can buy a piece of
dedicated land in Scotland which allows
you to officially call yourself a lord
or lady you can use your new title on
credit cards plain tick is an even
dating profiles it's also a fun way to
preserve the natural Woodlands of
Scotland while helping Global
reforestation efforts as with every
order established titles plants a tree
title packs give you at least one square
foot of dedicated land with a unique
plot number on a private estate in
edleston Scotland and an official
certificate with a Crest with the
holiday season coming up it's a great
novel present for your family or friends
and there are even couple title packs
available for partners so you can get
adjoining plots of land established
titles is running a massive early Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use
the code Flix 10 you get an additional
10 off so go to establishtitles.com
flicks10 to get your gifts now and there
are lots of great Disney Easter eggs
among the names of modern Asia's stores
you'll be able to spot Beauty in the
book painting painting on the wall a
magic mirror reference and a Grocer's
called a whole food world upon on
Jasmine and Aladdin's duet a whole new
world as Gisele's song continues we can
see smee's cheese and Le Chapo magic is
French for Magic Hat a fun tribute to
the Sorceress hatch from Fantasia over
here is Fay maren the French name for
the Fairy Godmother in Cinderella and
there's another cinder's reference with
The bibbidi-bobbidi Butchers and there's
a Mary poppin shout out with Mary
popover's Bakery and when shazelle goes
in search of her missing wand you can
see maid Marion's Dairy and numeria's
candleworks appropriately enough during
Morgan's Perfect song you can see a
Practically Perfect Pottery when Morgan
activates giselle's memory Tree in
andalasia she touches it and as it
lights up it transports her and Nancy up
to monrolesia and the golden lights then
fly into Morgan's room where they
reactivate her own memory tree some
think that Giselle foreshadowed at the
start of the movie this isn't anything a
little glitter couldn't fix the song
Love Power that Nancy sings has some
really strong Frozen Vibes with the
swirling magical memories and lights
reminding me a lot of Elsa's song into
the unknown Idina Menzel is of course
the voice of Elsa in the Frozen movies
and lines like Let It Grow and let it
glow in Nancy's big Power ballad or a
winky reference to let it go during the
song Morgan's torn up dress transforms
into a beautiful new one which is
disenchanted's take on the fairy
Godmother's transformation of
Cinderella's Rags into a ball gown the
dresses at malvina's Sidekicks Ruby and
Rosaline were for the night of the
festival are very similar to the one
Cinderella's nasty stepsisters wore to
the ball director Adam shankman has said
that malvina's minions are a sort of
echo of the stepsisters from Cinderella
when Gisela Morgan go dress shopping for
the festival pause the scene here and
you can spot this film's take on the
enchanted Rose from Beauty and the Beast
together with the nods to Belle's iconic
yellow ballroom dress from that movie
also on the right is a giant red apple a
reference to the Evil Queen's poisoned
apple and the costume next to it has
shades of Snow White's outfit the colors
don't match exactly but there's a yellow
skirt the top is a similar style to the
original and the red shawl feels like a
nod to the inside of Snow White's Cape
as for Morgan's blue dress that's a
shout out to Cinderella's ballroom dress
and the way wicked stepmother Giselle
Cuts up Morgan's dress so she can't go
to the Festival is a hat tip to how
Cinderella's stepsisters destroyed the
ballroom dress she made for herself in
the animated movie it's torn to shreds
but it's hardly fit for a maid plus
Giselle calling her stepdaughter a maid
is another Cinderella reference and when
Giselle realizes what she's turning into
she demonstrates a pose for pip which I
think has a Vibe of Disney's OG wicked
stepmother the evil queen oh actually
yeah I can totally see it as the movie
reaches its climax Vines from andalasia
begin to take over monrolesia covering
every building in sight which Echoes how
at the end of Sleeping Beauty Maleficent
grew a forest of thorny Vines over the
castle to try and stop Prince Philip
from reaching Aurora and in fact both
Robert and Tyler cut their way through
the vines similar to how the prince does
in Sleeping Beauty and to match how the
vines were taking over in the grand
finale giselle's luxurious ball gown was
designed to give the effect that leaves
and Vines were growing out of it so it
reflects the final stage of her evil
metamorphosis although Giselle is broken
out of her curse through the memory tree
Malvina captures Morgan and gives her a
sleeping potion sending her into a deep
Slumber like Aurora and Sleeping Beauty
Morgan is freed when Gisele gives up the
magic wand however she proves she's a
true daughter of shazal andalasia when
she takes a broken wand and says I wish
I was home with my mom which breaks the
curse and she then wakes up at home in
her own bed all of which is a shout out
to The Wizard of Oz and how Dorothy
wished herself home at the end of that
movie leaving the Fantasy Land of Oz
behind and finding herself back at home
in her bed in the real world after the
curse is lifted giselle's rest is a
clamshell Buckle a nice call out to The
Little Mermaid in Ariel another Disney
princess who was a big inspiration for
giselle's character an interesting
little detail which connects the magic
of andalasia and monroesia throughout
the movie is the purple and white flower
at the top of the andalasian wishing
wand known as the purple ballerina and
it appears in the opening scene where
pip is reading the story of the movie
later Morgan walks through a clearing in
the modern Asian Woods this is full of
them and they also hang from the
enchanted wishing well the flower
foreshadows how monroesia will pull the
magic out of andalasia by the end of the
film
although Robert's daughter Morgan was
recast in the sequel the actress Rachel
Covey from the original movie does have
a small but sweet Cameo as a modulation
girl who reminds Giselle about the
festival later that day what's tonight
the festival my lady and there's another
cool Cameo at the start of the film in
New York City with one of the movers all
right next up Monroeville that's actor
Matt savito from Enchanted who played
one of the workers in Times Square who
were repeatedly surprised by visitors
from andalasia arriving through the
manhole so what did you think of
disenchanted and did you notice any
other Easter eggs let me know in the
comments below if you love Disney movies
tap here for another video just like
this and if you enjoyed this video do
leave a thumbs up I really appreciate it
thanks for enjoying this movie with me
and hope you have a marvelous movie
loving week yupikai movie lovers